share your your mom is still with this
yes this it's not funny but I do think a
brilliant bit of advice that you should
share is her five-year rule if it
doesn't matter in five years it doesn't
matter isn't that bad happens you can't
think will I care about this right so
I'm you know and it always helps me it
always comes in handy no I read that and
I just thought bass pretties actually
you're genius yeah nice really really
good and I wonder did she come up with
that thinking when you were a teenager
cuz you were quite a wild child I would
say all right I was wilder when I was
nine years old than I ever was as a
teenager I ran away from home I stole a
horse I jumped on a freighter and kept
going until my girlfriend started crying
for her mother oh how did you get back I
called my mother but this is no like you
say you I want this is but this is
shares I don't know if it's her only but
it's certainly your first mugshot
oh my god that's not true I did it but I
didn't get arrested for it what's that
from then that's my school picture when
the eighth grade I swear to God I would
cop to it if it was true a Los Angeles
police some like rag magazine I actually
did too but so alright this I learned
how to drive when I was 11 so my girl
wild reef it wasn't a big deal
so my friends had a boyfriend and he
said he had to go in we were two bowling
alley he said I have to go in and have
to say something to a friend I'll be
there for four seconds and we waited and
we waited and he didn't come out and so
then the girl said sure you know how to
drive let's just drive around the
parking lot I said okay and then he
didn't come out so sure let's just drive
around the block and so he didn't come
out and I just thought well this I I'm
gonna take us out and so we went to a
drive-in to get something to drink and
we got arrested
not exactly arrested just taken to jail
honestly just just taking the trail this
with a warning this is the morning
[Music]
you